Меморіальний комплекс пам'яті жертв геноциду в Єревані.
Щороку двадцять четвертого квітня сюди приходять чимало людей.
Але через відставку прем'єр-міністра Сержа Саргсяна під тиском масових протестів
нинішній День загальновірменської жалоби став водночас і днем загальних радощів.
У центрі Єревана - святкова атмосфера.
Я - один зі щасливих громадян Вірменії.
Зараз громадяни Вірменії зрозуміли, що вони реально можуть щось змінити.
Після перемоги, розумієш, який може бути настрій?
Як новонароджена дитина. Диво сталося у Вірменії.
Без крові революцію зробив народ.
25 квітня виконувач обов'язків прем'єра Карен Карапетян
та лідер опозиції Нікол Пашинян домовилися провести перемовини.
Місцеві спостерігачі вважають, що вони можуть стати довгими й непростими.
Вірменія - близький союзник Росії.
Саргсяна вважали проросійським політиком.
Але заради справедливості варто відзначити,
що Карен Карапетян був топ-менеджером "Газпрому".
Тому багато хто передбачає, що він теж матиме проросійську позицію.
А лідери протестного руху і партії,
яка їх підтримує,  налаштовані прозахідно.
При цьому експерти відзначають,
що зовсім не партії стали головною рушійною силою протестів.
Під час цих багатоденних протестів першочергову роль відіграли не партії,
зокрема, і Нікола Пашиняна, лідера протестного руху, а громадяни цієї країни.
Залишається сподіватися, що цих активістів
та представників їхніх інтересів також залучать до діалогу.
Проте для цього у Вірменії немає добрих структурних та інституційних умов.
Нині опозиція вимагає провести дострокові вибори до парламенту.
Але, на жаль, сучасна історія Вірменії не може похвалитися чесними виборами.
Часто вибори завершувалися вуличними протестами й мітингами.
На думку колумніста DW Костянтина Еґґерта, казати про остаточну перемогу опозиції
та списувати правлячу еліту у Вірменії - зарано.
Поки не зрозуміло, що відбудеться після цієї відставки.
Швидше за все, карабаський клан захоче замінити Саргсяна на когось зі "своїх"…
У будь-якому разі, такий мирний відхід від влади людини,
яка збиралась сидіти ще багато років, – це ляпас зовнішній політиці Москви.
Тим часом, на площі Республіки, де ще кілька днів тому відбувалися жорсткі затримання,
у день після відставки Саргсяна активісти вирішили провести прибирання.
І це теж є символічним для молодого, але зміцнілого громадянського суспільства Вірменії.